hyperscape is at its strongest when
you're in the midst of its frantic
battles that encourage you to fight not
only efficiently
but quickly the game's vertically
influenced environment and quick loot
management all contribute to fast and
fun fights but hyperscape is also held
back by that same environment and
collection of weapons and hacks it all
combines into a battle royale game that
has great moments but ultimately feels
like it relies too much on randomness to
lead to satisfying victories
if you've ever played a battle royale
game before then the goal of hyperscape
is an old song and dance by this point
players begin each match by dropping
onto a battlefield with nothing to their
name
forced to survive by any means necessary
as the match progresses the battlefield
shrinks increasing the likelihood of
firefights
breaking out amongst the survivors
hyperscape breaks from the traditional
battle royale formula and how you win
you can either be the last one standing
or claim the crown that spawns at the
end of each match
and hold on to it for 45 seconds without
dying hyperscape has a variety of
weapons each of which is diverse enough
to offer different play styles
there's nothing wildly different about
any of them in comparison to most sci-fi
shooters but there's at least some good
sound design behind hyperscape's weapons
you can identify what's being shot at
you
via the noise that each gun makes
however though the in-match meta is
fairly balanced some guns are just
better
a lot of fights take place in enclosed
spaces lending greater utility to
certain firearms like the mammoth mk1
shotgun and hex fire lmg
pretty much the exact same thing can be
said about hyperscapes hacks
the game's version of hero abilities as
opposed to attaching specific abilities
to certain characters
hyperscape has different abilities that
you can pick up and equip you can only
hold two at a time
and since each hat can accomplish
different tasks you can curate very
different builds based on what you pick
up
but like weapons there are some hacks
that just seem ideal for success the
most important use of a hack is to run
from a fight you can't handle with your
guns alone which emphasizes the ones
geared towards traversal or escape
this leads to a bit of stagnation in
hyperscapes in match meta you can win
with any combination of weapons and
hacks but there's definitely a path that
has a higher chance of success
and in something like a battle royale
where loot is random this can
occasionally lead to matches where the
odds are stacked against you from the
beginning
if no one in your squad managed to find
the weapons and hacks that can lead to
an ideal loadout
of course how you move is just as
important as what weapons and hacks you
have equipped
and there's something to be said about
actual skill when it comes to first
person shooters
it's also worth pointing out that most
of the guns feel balance and their
respective damage output and fire rate
none of them feel too overpowered but
since so much of hyperscapes battles
take place inside multi-story buildings
it lowers the usefulness of long-range
scoped weapons like the protocol 5
and dragonfly whereas most battlerail
games have horizontally built maps
hyperscape takes place on the vertically
focused neo arcadia
most buildings are at least 3 stories
and stairways and jump pads ensure you
almost always have a means of accessing
their rooftops
many battles in hyperscape quickly
transition between the ground the tops
of buildings and mid-air you have to be
just as aware of an attack coming from
above or below you
as you do from the front or the back
hyperscape definitely leans towards a
faster pace a speed that's certainly
encouraged via its mechanics
diving into a crouch from a sprint will
fling you forward in an aggressive slide
and a double jump and ledge grab allows
you to more easily maneuver around the
map in comparison to most battle royales
sprinting sliding climbing and using
navigation based hacks to parkour around
the map is joyful fun
there's a real sense of momentum to your
movements as you catapult yourself
through the air and over or around
obstacles i think i've gotten a bigger
adrenaline rush from expertly pulling
off several impressive movements in
quick succession to escape a battle then
i have winning one when it comes to
navigating the immediate area
hyperscape does a lot to make you feel
like a superhuman parkour expert
however it's difficult to know where
you're going once you've finished up a
fight or looted all the buildings around
you
outside of the major landmarks most of
the buildings and locations in neo
arcadia all look exactly the same
granted this makes it easy to spot
enemies as they're highlighted with a
red outline when you aim at them that
really stands out so the map design
helps in that regard but it's all too
much of the same to aid in exploration
and navigation
this is a huge problem with how zone
closure works in hyperscape instead of
the closing ring seen in most battle
royale games and hyperscape individual
zones slowly delete themselves over time
it's a cool looking effect to an
intriguing take on battle royale's ring
closure but it ultimately makes
everything in the environment look
even more similar making it incredibly
difficult to get your bearings while
you're trying to reach a safe zone
an arrow at least points in the
direction of the nearest safe zone but a
straight path to safety is not always
the best one
thankfully even though you'll be
frequently stopping to look at your map
in hyperscape you won't have to do the
same for loot hyperscape forego is an
attachment based system when it comes to
improving your arsenal for a system
that's far
simpler say you find and equip a weapon
finding him picking up the same weapon
will improve the stats of the one you're
currently holding
this system applies to your hacks too
allowing you to lower the cooldown
and increase the offensive potential of
your special abilities by discovering
copies of the ones you already have
equipped
this ensures matches remain fast you're
not stopping to root through your
inventory
because there's nothing to manage
hyperscape has a rather nifty revive
mechanic too
it might be my favorite version i've
seen in a battle royale yet when you die
in hyperscape your digital echo falls
out of your corpse
in this form you're limited to only
being able to move and ping but enemies
can't see you if your living squad mates
manage to kill an enemy player they can
interact with the corpse to bring you
back to life this gives deadplayer
something to do you can scout ahead for
your living squadmates and actively
contribute to ensuring your team wins
its next fight so that you can be
revived with the start of season 1 the
first principle hyperscape gets a battle
pass daily and weekly challenges and
tons of new rewards to unlock
exactly what a game like hyperscape
needs with only one map for its two
permanent modes
solo and squads there's just not enough
there to keep playing the game every day
without an additional incentive
i'm not a huge fan of hyperscape's
battle pass though it's got a free track
and paid one which normally would be
fine
except that nearly half of the items on
the free track can't be accessed unless
you have prime gaming which requires
paying for amazon prime so both tracks
require cash to complete
the battle pass highlights that you're
missing items if you don't have prime
gaming too
which feels a little predatory the new
characters are really the only reward
worth pursuing as they do have some
impact on your personal experience
albeit one that is pretty insignificant
none of the characters change the
gameplay but each sounds off with unique
one-liners there's no real backstory or
reason to like any of the characters
though their backstories are shallow and
hyperscape story doesn't do much to
flesh them out
so even though you can buy more
characters in the in-game store i'm not
eager to spend real world money to meet
more of them
without a doubt the best new additions
with season 1 are the new weapon and
hack
between the two i like the new magnet
hack more it has a welcome method of
controlling distance between you and an
enemy and also opens up new ways to use
neo-arcadia's environment to her
advantage the new dragonfly assault
rifle isn't as impactful i don't have
any issues with it though it's a
well-balanced gun that doesn't
negatively impact the in-match meta
in any significant way hyperscape is an
okay battle royale game it has solid
weapons and hero like hack abilities but
you're at the mercy of being lucky
enough to get what you need to have a
higher chance of winning
the battleground doesn't help in this
regard since it's difficult to know
where you're going and make a plan about
where to loot next without stopping to
open the map
at least the individual moments in
hyperscape are fun a match could be
ruined by the randomness working against
you but that doesn't stop the little
moments from being any less fun and how
ridiculously silly they are
[Applause]
you